the FBI doubled the reward for
information leading to the arrest of the
fugitive who mailed a threatening
manifesto to the White House the reward
for Joseph's jackubowski is now twenty
thousand dollars the FBI said he may
have changed his appearance it released
new images showing what he could look
like with a shaved head and face other
pictures depict his tattoos David beg no
is in Janesville Wisconsin at the
command post for the manhunt David good
morning good morning so the FBI says
he's armed dangerous he's got a cache of
weapons and tactical gear we've got some
new reporting this morning about an
apparent apology letter that he wrote
more on that in a moment but first here
at the command post you've got a hundred
and fifty law enforcement officers who
are actively looking for this guy and we
saw him in action last night we were
there as heavily armed officers
surrounded this shed behind a home in
Janesville looking for jackubowski he
wasn't there but they are chasing down
more than 400 leads as this manhunt
stretches well beyond Wisconsin on April
4th jackubowski had a friend record him
as he mailed a handwritten 161 page
manifesto to president Truong Nhu
revolution
police say after he mailed it he broke
into the Armageddon gun store and stole
18 firearms including an m16 rifle two
gun silencers and ammunition newly
released court documents revealed
Jakubowski allegedly dove headfirst
through the broken out window of the
front door to enter the business his
sister whom he lived with until the
morning of the burglary told the
detectives she found a draft of a letter
in it he apologized to the gun shop
owner for the theft of the weapons and
thanked him for protecting the Second
Amendment rights of the citizens he's
been successful so far in disappearing
Rock County sheriff Roberts Bowden and
Janesville Police Chief David Moore say
this is a national investigation this
got make you worried this guy makes me
worried this guy is dedicated to what he
believes is his cause he is dedicated to
seeing that this becomes a revolution my
concern is not just our community
it's my concern is nationwide he could
be anyplace and we just don't know what
that endgame and what that plan is
so jackubowski burned his vehicle his
family's worried because it's about the
only thing he had he hadn't work since
January
Nora his stepfather told us that there
were he may try and end this with some
type of suicide by cop all right David
thank you they are on alert there